amis téléspectateurs bonjour quelle joie
oui de vous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle saison dès maintenant nouveau
plateau nouveau décor même principe on
revient toujours avec plaisir et
toujours avec vous sur l'actualité
politique de la semaine vous savez
comment ça marche hashtag et maintenant
si vous souhaitez réagir autour de moi
pour cette première des invités qui sont
triés sur le volet la crème de la crème
de l'analyse politique vous les
connaissez déjà ils nous font l'honneur
le grand honneur de revenir cette année
Roselyne Bachelot comment allez-vous
très très bien et vraiment quel plateau
superbe sublime on est content de
revenir vous êtes ancienne ministre
éditorialiste votre dernier livre
682 jours le bal des hypocrites asilis
le corps est également avec nous bonjour
vous êtes rédactrice en chef opinion au
JDD Christophe agiton bonjour bonjour
vous êtes sociologue militants à terme
mondialiste et le redoutable Jean-Luc
est également avec nous Jean-Luc mano
bonjour bonjour ça y est en
communication fondateur
conseil merci d'être là dans cette
émission on se demandera si l'abus
d'Emmanuel Macron est dangereux pour la
santé lui qui a retoqué des campagnes de
prévention contre l'alcool on verra si
un référendum sur l'immigration arrange
vraiment les affaires de la droite on
essaiera de savoir ce qui fait le charme
d'Édouard Philippe lui qui fait une
rentrée politique très peu discrète
disons le et puis on débattra des
violences policières plus de deux mois
après la mort du jeune Naël ma séance
est ouverte merci président Larcher mais
d'abord comment en est-on arrivé là hier
encore le Maroc et la France
entretenaient des relations privilégiées
mais aujourd'hui comme une catastrophe
s'abat sur le Royaume Raban ne décroche
plus son téléphone lorsque notre numéro
apparaît alors à qui la faute il y a
peut-être celle d'Emmanuel Macron c'est
en tout cas ce que nous dit Dominique de
Villepin écoutez-le
nous n'avons jamais connu une
accumulation de tension et aussi durable
donc il faut prendre en compte cela
c'est vrai que ça a commencé sous
Emmanuel Macron et qu'il est important
que nous très rapidement que nous
trouvions le moyen de supérer cette
situation il est important pour la
France de mettre son drapeau dans sa
poche de mettre sa susceptibilité dans
sa poche on reviendra sur les
responsabilités éventuelles mais Rosine
c'est quoi c'est une brouille passagère
ou c'est une crise qui est plus profonde
que ça
d'abord en réaction à Dominique
deVillepin mettre son drapeau dans sa
poche me paraît à une image hasardeuse
de la part d'un ancien ministre des
Affaires étrangères
pardon à la mi-dominique de l'avoir de
l'avoir dit
il y a il y a sans doute comme dans les
brouilles de ménage de la faute de côté
sans doute et des incompréhensions mais
je dois dire que la
logomachie marocaine me paraît quand
même étrange après avoir dit c'est une
question de compétence je pense que la
compétence des équipes françaises de
sauvetage est reconnue d'avoir
argué de la proximité le Qatar et les
Émirats arabes sont pas vraiment plus
proches que la France après avoir dit
qu'il fallait tout juger au prisme du de
l'affaire du Sahara à X espagnol du
Sahara Occidental on voit que bah les
Anglais qui ont été retenus en fait ont
la même mission que on l'a même position
que la France donc moi je pense qu'il y
a un problème géostratégique beaucoup
plus globale avec le avec le Maroc et
que une fois de plus dans une monarchie
fragilisée qui ne répond pas aux
aspirations démocratiques de sa jeunesse
une jeunesse qui souffre beaucoup de
d'impérissier économique il faut
replacer ça dans la stratégie dans la
géostratégie africaine finalement dans
le camp marocain on va reparler ah oui
moi je mets la bague mais Jean-Luc cette
relation franco-marocaine elle était on
parlait de relation privilégiées
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé comment en
est-on arrivé là très simplement d'un
mot c'est un moment pour que que
Roselyne serait bien que que Dominique
de Villepin relise le discours sur la
grande et vieilles nations qu'il avait
fait devant le Conseil de sécurité parce
que il y a une attitude la manifestement
un peu différente façon au roi du Maroc
la deuxième la deuxième chose on est
arrivé là parce qu'il y a une brouille
il y a une brouille pour plein de
raisons
[Musique]
au niveau d'Atlas que je connais bien
par ailleurs dans lequel c'est une
population paysanne berbère amazirte qui
a été vraiment décimé bon mais sur une
zone assez petite il y a pas eu beaucoup
de morts à Marrakech par exemple on
craignait qui en est beaucoup on n'a pas
eu beaucoup bon assez petit et avec des
routes qui s'étaient effondrées à cause
du tremblement de terre lui-même donc on
avait pas besoin comment Turquie en
Syrie etc d'avoir autant de ou comme
aujourd'hui en Libye malheureusement
comment on vient de le voir avec cette
horrible inondation d'avoir autant de
d'équipes sur place et le pays le Maroc
n'a payé souverain alors évidemment il y
a les raisons qui ont été données je
partage bon mais ça ne me choque pas et
je trouve qu'il est pas normal qu'on
s'indigne autant en sachant que
l'Allemagne par exemple qui est un pays
qui est très proche du Maroc et
l'immigration absolument énorme plus
importante encore encore en France et
des liens historiques n'a pas non plus
et des retenu bref c'est pas une affaire
voilà je le prendrai comme ça après il y
a des vrais problèmes entre les Russes
dans la région entre Maroc et France ce
dont vous avez parlé et l'affaire du
Sahara est quand même une épine dans le
pied
je pense que c'est un sujet
à faire d'espionnage Pegasus
représentative de rapprochement vous en
avez pas parlé à tentative de
rapprochement français avec l'Algérie et
le dossier du Sahara Occidental c'est ce
dossier du Sahara basilic peut être qui
crispe le plus en tout cas du côté
marocain alors d'abord de choses je
voudrais simplement réagir est-ce que
des monsieur alors c'est une réalité
quand il y a une urgence en effet les
pays doivent gérer les associations
humanitaires qui viennent qui viennent
aider et donc il faut les trier donc ça
on n'a pas je crois en effet de jugement
à porter sur le choix du Maroc mais on
ne peut pas s'empêcher tout de même de
se poser une question quand on sait que
les pays qui ont été retenus ont reconnu
ce Sahara occidental pour la plupart
pour l'Espagne le Qatar
oui mais enfin reconnaissez que ça ça
pose quand même question
marocain du point de vue marocain et
ensuite il y a évidemment donc cette
histoire bizarre on en a parlé côté
français moi je trouve que c'est plutôt
un honneur qui Emmanuel Macron on
propose son aide à leur qui lui affaire
Pegasus donc ça quand même et il faut le
souligner
il y a une autre question je pense qu'on
va se poser c'est de la relation de
l'Algérie Emmanuel Macron a essayé de
privilégier sa relation avec l'Algérie
au dépend du royaume marocain en mettant
de côté cette relation qui était déjà
privilégiée on sait que les relations
entre le Maroc et l'Algérie ne sont pas
au beau fixes et il a essayé de le faire
dans une sorte d'idée de repentance qui
ne fonctionne même pas avec l'Algérie
qui s'est rapproché de la Russie
absolument et donc moi ça me paraît
assez loin et je pense qu'on peut
souligner en effet le
l'erreur d'Emmanuel Macron de ce point
de vue là et je crois que la réaction du
Maroc
on dit beaucoup en gros il fallait pas
se non pas se réconcilier avec l'Algérie
parce que je crois que ça fonctionne
extrêmement difficile mais qui est une
tentative de la part d'Emmanuel Macron
de stabiliser des relations difficiles
en connaissance de l'affaire Houda ou
des choses très importantes qui ont été
faits
2016 expliquer que que la France est
responsable de crimes contre l'humanité
en Algérie cela va dans le même dans le
même sillon que de dire oui mais c'est
un c'est un chef d'État c'est un chef
d'État ce n'est pas un historien
de la France où on sait que
l'immigration algérienne aujourd'hui
issus
les polémiques n'ont tout simplement pas
lieu d'être on va l'écouter je vous
redonne la parole Jean-Luc dans un
instant j'ai vu beaucoup de polémiques
ces derniers jours qui n'ont pas lieu
d'être nous sommes là nous avons la
possibilité d'apporter une aide
humanitaire directe c'est évidemment à
Sa Majesté le Roi au gouvernement du
Maroc de manière pleinement souveraine
d'organiser la date internationale
et donc nous sommes à disposition de
leur choix souverains c'est depuis la
première seconde ce que nous faisons de
manière tout à fait normale j'aurais que
vous êtes d'accord on en fait un peu
trop sur cette brouille entre la France
et le Maroc où il y a vraiment quelque
chose de problématique là-dedans je
pense on en fait trop mais il y a pas
seulement le fait il y a la souveraineté
du Maroc bon va se mettre d'accord assez
rapidement sur évidemment personne va
faire rentrer des sauveteurs par
effraction au Maroc on vient les pays
viennent si on leur si on leur demande
mais là on est dans un quelque chose
d'un peu plus rude quand même quand vous
voyez un reportage on a des sauveteurs
qui disent on nous a accepté à condition
qu'on n'est pas les cussons bleu blanc
rouge sur notre notre uniforme de
sauveteur on voit bien que on n'est pas
juste dans une question de logistique
d'organisation en plus la situation vous
disiez que vous connaissiez peu
d'attache là-bas aussi dans la dans
toute la région du house manifestement
quand on regarde l'étendue des dégâts je
veux dire plus de sauveteurs et plus
d'intervention serait sans doute serait
sans mais ça c'est effectivement
l'affaire du l'affaire du Maroc mais
l'idée que on aurait fait une erreur en
essayant de se réconcilier ou en tout
cas d'apaiser avec l'Algérie par peur de
nuire à la relation avec le Maroc c'est
pas une position diplomatique tenable
enfin il y a des principes
internationaux notamment sur la question
du Sahara et on peut pas choisir au
Maghreb notre partenaire au détriment
d'un autre c'est à dire dire bah on va
donner raison au Marocain surtout et
avoir des relations détestables avec
l'Algérie ou le contraire
est une position
patronale après l'échec après après le
fait que les efforts fait avec l'Algérie
ne soient pas payé de retour c'est une
vraie c'est une vraie question mais
voyez les les alliances et les relations
diplomatiques ça se fait pas comme ça
par vengeance ou par ou par rétorsion
enfin un bilan Christophe de cette de se
rapprochement notamment avec Alger
comment quel adjectif vous retenez c'est
un échec c'est un deux évidemment ça n'a
pas fonctionné parce que ça va demander
beaucoup de temps
parce que les blessures sont tellement
profondes tellement profondes ça ne se
résoudre pas en deux jours mais je pense
et là je suis d'accord avec vous deux
qu'il était juste de faire cet effort je
quand on parle de crime contre
l'humanité ça a été évidemment la guerre
d'Algérie mais c'est la colonisation la
colonisation de l'Algérie est un crime
permanent regardez les enfumates de
général Bugeaud c'est-à-dire qu'en fait
les populations civiles étaient dans des
grottes on les a enfumées pour qu'elles
meurt toutes bon le général Bugeot était
celui qui était le chef du corps
expéditionnaire en Algérie
et
notre propre famille et je pense que
c'est dangereux
on comprenne que ça va prendre du temps
mais après il y a le dossier du sarot
occidental et ça je pense qu'il faut
quand même en dire deux mots parce que
c'est une question qui est à la fois une
question de principe et puis qui est
politiquement compliqué c'est une
question de principe parce que des
colonisation a toujours abouti au fait
que les pays deviennent indépendants il
y a deux cas qui ne se sont pas produits
comme ça Timor lesté ou à la fin de
l'Empire quand il s'effondrer l'Empire
portugais les Indiens ont envahi et le
Sahara occidental où les Espagnols sont
partis avec la mort du général Franco et
où le Maroc à ce moment-là a envahi le
pays pour des raisons strictement
internes n'oublions pas Cassan II à
l'époque avait eu deux coups d'État qui
avait failli réussir comme l'autre que
il était en crise permanente dans son
pays et que donc en mobilisant avec une
ferveur nationaliste dans ce qui s'était
appelé à l'époque la Marche Verte il
pensait régler tous les problèmes de 5
ans
que ça dure et c'est une épine dans le
pied qui coûte une fortune au Maroc il y
a 10 ans il y a eu encore des émeutes et
elle a eu très importante c'est ça la
base du conflit avec l'Algérie donc
c'est un dossier explosif mais qui lui
aussi demandera à être réglé par les
Nations Unies
on vous accepté Roseline on va vous
apporter
l'immigration avec cette question
faut-il régulariser les 100 papiers dans
les métiers en tension vous allez nous
le dire voisine dans un instant cette
semaine une trentaine de parlementaires
allant du modèle à europécologie les
Verts ont signé une tribune que vous
voyez dans Libération il demande la
régularisation des travailleurs sans
papier qui sont souvent vous le savez en
première ligne dans des secteurs comme
la restauration ou le BTP le
gouvernement prépare une loi immigration
pour cet hiver la droite sans félicite
mais ne veut pas entendre parler de
régularisation écoutez on en a toujours
fait une ligne l'article 3 si à cet
article 3 ce sera non si au poste très
clairement on l'a toujours dit on le
combattra avec tous les outils
juridiques que la Constitution nous
offre faut-il régulariser les
travailleurs sans papiers dans les
métiers en tension deux invités sur ce
plateau ne sont pas du tout d'accord
mais alors vous allez le voir vraiment
pas pas du tout d'accord c'est un duel
les amis vous connaissez le principe 45
secondes chacun d'un côté asilis de
l'autre Christophe Azilis vous commencez
vous avez 45 secondes vous allez me dire
pourquoi vous il ne faut pas régulariser
les sans-papiers dans ces métiers là
alors d'abord ce statut de métier en
tension à mon avis écrit un nouvel appel
d'air on voit ce qui se passe à
Lampedusa actuellement des centaines de
bateaux de migrants qui arrivent on
importe de la misère et on sait en
France qu'on a un problème avec le
chômage en 2,3 millions de chômeurs
c'est très stressant ce TikTok
et donc il y a une question en français
la question de la revalorisation des
salaires comment est-ce qu'on rend ces
métiers attractifs mais à mon avis la
question de l'immigration ne sera pas la
solution parce qu'elle pose d'autres
problèmes qui est le problème de la
formation d'abord de ces personnes et
ensuite de la de leur intégration à la
culture française à la société française
et donc voilà donc non
et la droite a raison de tenir face à
Emmanuel Macron face à la majorité
présidentielle qui on le voit est très
divisé sur ce sujet bravo vous avez
resté la pression du tic tac c'est à
VOUS Christophe vous avez 45 secondes
vous êtes maître de vos émotions 45
secondes vous allez expliquer pourquoi
oui il faut régulariser d'abord parce
qu'il faut quand même qu'on comprenne
que ce pays ne fonctionnerait pas sans
les travailleurs immigrés c'est vrai
chez nous mais c'est vrai aussi aux
Etats-Unis dans tout le reste de
l'Europe on est deux exemples à métro à
5h30 du matin ou à 6h du matin regardez
la tête des gens qui sont là il y en a
pas beaucoup qui sont Français de souche
au sens qui sont blancs et qui sont là
depuis des générations mais le pays
tient grâce à eux c'est eux qui
nettoient aujourd'hui les bureaux c'est
eux qui font tourner toute une série de
choses comme les services des aéroports
et des tas d'autres mais allez à
l'hôpital et là vous aurez d'autres
types de catégories les médecins
marocains tunisiens syriens sans eux il
y a plus l'hôpital public sans eux il y
a plus d'urgence donc il y a une vraie
question sur la capacité à comprendre
l'importance de ces immigrés et il y a
aujourd'hui les métiers en tension dans
la restauration dans l'état d'autres
secteurs et si on est régularise pas on
aura des difficultés majeures et qui ne
seront pas résolues par l'appel au
chômage au chômage après Azilis vous
avez déjà fait votre duel ces Rosine qui
va nous trancher tout ça
je vais dire que je suis absolument pour
la régularisation régularisation pour la
régularisation
et évidemment de ces de ces métiers de
il n'y a que des avantages d'ailleurs
avantage évidemment pour les
travailleurs qui recouvrent un statut
une protection sociale qui ne sont pas
utilisées à du Mans avec des maigres
salaires et pas de protection et ce qui
protège aussi les les Français déjà
installés et il y a vraiment que des
avantages je suis alors très réservé sur
par contre les quotas d'immigrations qui
sont proposés parce que ça a l'air de
supposer que il n'y a que sur les
métiers comment dit-on les premiers de
corvées qui sont concernés vous avez
évoqué des médecins marocains ils
savez-vous qu'il y a plus un médecin
béninois en Île-de-France qu'il n'y en a
au Bénin donc après avoir pillé les
ressources naturelles on pillerait les
ressources intellectuelles de ces
pays-là qui ont besoin de garder aussi
des ingénieurs des médecins des
techniciens donc je suis très réservé
sur les affaires des affaires des quotas
et troisième élément de discussion la
chute démographique de notre pays fait
que nous aurons besoin de travailler
immigrés pour compenser cette chute
démocratie je vous donne la parole
Jean-Luc le nombre de sans-papiers en
France paradéfinition il est pas
officiel
à mesurer mais il serait entre 400 000
et 1 million selon les différents
estimations Jean-Luc
il faut se poser la question peut-être
moi je me la pose un peu à l'envers ne
pas régulariser ça sert à quoi
ça sert uniquement à laisser des gens
qui payent des cotisations qui
travaillent qui sont dans les métiers ou
des Français souvent ne veulent pas ne
veulent plus aller à vivre dans des
conditions effroyables
et moi j'en ai alors un peu ras-le-bol
de l'idée de l'appel d'air l'appel d'air
qui fait que des gens viennent en France
ou en Europe c'est l'appel d'air de la
misère c'est l'appel d'air des
dictatures c'est la paire d'elle des
échecs de nos politiques de coopération
internationale pour une grande partie
enfin écoutez personne ne vient parce
que il se dit peut-être qu'un jour je
serai régularisé on vient parce qu'on a
faim on a faim parce que ses enfants ont
faim parce qu'il faut envoyer des moyens
donc c'est un fantasme de cette histoire
de d'appel d'air d'ailleurs il y a
tellement peu d'appels d'air que pour un
certain nombre ils viennent en France
avec une idée cette partie au
Royaume-Uni car si vous allez si vous
allez à Dunkerque vous allez dans ces
régions là ils disent pas contrairement
à ce que dit une partie de la droite
c'est parce qu'on a un système tellement
laxiste la sécurité sociale les immigrés
gagnent plus qu'un travailleur français
ils veulent ils veulent ils veulent
partir ils meurent ils meurent en il
meurt en traversant pour aller pour
vouloir aller en en Grande-Bretagne donc
nous en avons besoin notre économie à
les structurer comme ça dans vos besoins
pas seulement dans les métiers premiers
de corvée on en a besoin pour beaucoup
d'autres dans beaucoup d'autres maisons
infirmières médecins etc
en plus les patrons demandent qu'on
régularise
donc il y a matière effectivement à
régulariser et de ce point de vue je
veux dire je trouve que cette tribune
transpartisane la libération
ça éclaire un peu la rentrée voilà
juste pour réagir à ce que disait
azilise c'est le patronat qui demande
c'est régularisation et elle se disait
ça permet de faire baisser de mettre la
pression sur les salaires qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez Christian vous êtes
économiste
mais j'en suis pas sûr vous connaissez
bien mais j'en suis pas sûr parce que
aujourd'hui les patrons de la
restauration sont obligés d'augmenter un
peu les salaires dans tous les cas et je
ne pense pas qu'une régularisation de
quelques dizaines ou centaines de
milliers de personnes résoudraient cette
question là non j'y crois vraiment pas
et je pense que dans tous les arguments
de la droite il y a tout ce qui a dit
Jean-Luc Malo ou Roselyne Bachelot que
je partage totalement et je vais pas
répéter il y en a un autre qui
m'apparaîtrait dangereux c'est l'idée
qu'il faudrait limiter le nombre
d'étudiants étrangers les étudiants
étrangers c'est une richesse incroyable
pour notre pays incroyable prenez les
mathématiques vous savez que la France
est réputé pour son école de
mathématiques les médailles files de ce
compte par dizaines on connaît ça mais
en fait quand vous prenez dans le détail
l'essentiel aujourd'hui de ceux qui
passent des thèses en mathématiques sont
algériens et marocains et c'est eux qui
permettent au Laboratoire de sciences
mathématiques en l'occurrence de
progresser donc on a besoin de cet
échange là et ce que j'espère là aussi
je suis d'accord avec rosé une Bachelot
c'est qu'une partie de ces étudiants qui
sont les étudiants très qualifiés
retournent dans leur pays et puis céder
ces pays pour pouvoir retrouver des
capacités et là vraiment pour moi c'est
une question importante et des pays
comme l'Australie ou la Grande-Bretagne
appuie en perm sur la nécessité d'avoir
plus d'étudiants étrangers parce qu'ils
savent que c'est l'avenir
c'est qu'il faut pas la peine
c'est vrai ou pas un sort de tabou sur
cette question des régularisations le
gouvernement fait cette proposition il y
a un an et demi et là on le sent encore
l'hésite
pas et parce que ça dévoile le clivage
et la problématique finalement de la
jeunesse du macronisme quand Emmanuel
Macron a fait sa campagne de 2016 il a
il a porté un discours plutôt pro
immigration et ensuite on voit qu'au
gouvernement et notamment avec
l'impulsion du ministre de l'Intérieur
Gérald Darmanin il a une droiteisation
qui s'est faite sur ces questions là et
donc là on voit avec cet appel qui est
en effet signé par des personnalités
très largement
on voit qu'il y a ce clivage
gauche-droite qui réapparaît au sein
même de la macronie et donc c'est pour
ça que
le gouvernement aujourd'hui et de ce
point de vue ils vont avoir beaucoup de
mal à passer ce texte 149,3 puisque la
droite si ce n'est maintenu votre appât
et la gauche demande des infections qui
sont à mon avis trop importantes pour le
gouvernement très rapidement avait
raison de dire que c'est global moi j'ai
des exemples comprenez on peut pas dire
à des étudiants c'est un vrai question
vous ne pouvez plus venir en France
alors ils vont où bah là on les
accueille en Chine ils vont ils vont au
Canada ils vont aux États-Unis et 10 ans
après ils sont médecins chefs de service
patron d'hôpitaux dans leur pays et on
dit c'est bizarre ils prennent pas les
scanners français c'est étrange ils
achètent des scènes bah oui ça c'est des
scanners sur les endroits qui qui qui
connaissent avec les pays qui les ont
accueillis des gens pour
le ménage
donc le sujet là vous vous décalez le
sujet pour essayer de défendre au
restaurant et c'est pas mal pour vous
servent quand même et que vous n'avez
pas de gens qui les amis
revalorisés pour que n'importe quel
français en fait accepte ces ce métier
que tu arriveras au Parlement au mois de
novembre et comme ça des amis c'est la
mission vous reviendrez pour en parler
et si c'était lui aussi c'était Edouard
Philippe les Français l'adorent
personnalité politique préférée de nos
comptes patriotes selon les sondages
cette semaine il a fait une rentrée
politique en fanfare sortie de son livre
mercredi journée parlementaire dans la
foulée par image tF1 France Inter et
Douard était partout d'où cette question
Monsieur le Premier Ministre êtes-vous
déjà dans les starting blocks pour 2027
responsable politique qui vient de voir
en disant la prochaine élection
présidentielle on s'en fout c'est pas le
sujet mais il vous raconterait du
caramel ce qui vous disent qu'il n'y
pense jamais vous raconte des cracks
ceux qui pensent en permanence et qui ne
pensent qu'à ça sont des dingues après
2027 c'est loin non alors bon 2027 c'est
loin
on sait très bien que les Chéries des
sondages sont les gens qui ne sont pas
aux affaires on l'a vu sur d'autres sur
d'autres personnalités toutefois bon il
est clair que Édouard Philippe se
positionne pour la candidature à la
présidence de la République en 2027 et
la seule stratégie balade dans ce
domaine c'est à dire de poser ses pions
de de créer des réseaux de mobiliser un
certain nombre de relais d'opinion
autour de lui de gérer cette image de sa
maladie qui peut être un élément
perturbateur pour pas que dans l'oubli
qui se ferait entre
l'apparition très nette de sa maladie et
son image il y a une sorte d'effet de
surprise que cette affaire-là soit
derrière lui au moment de sa candidature
il gère ça de façon parfaite ça ne veut
pas dire qu'il sera élu regardez ce
sondage quand on demande aux Français
qui pourra sembler la droite et le
centre Édouard Philippe arrive très
largement en tête avec 42% juste
derrière on retrouve Bruno Le Maire 27%,
ensuite Gérald Darmanin avec 22% c'est
un sondage Opinionway pour le Parisien
on date du 2 septembre qu'est-ce qui
plaît chez Édouard Philippe auprès des
Françaises ils disent selon vous d'abord
simplement une réaction sur notre
thématique et je vais du tout si je vois
l'émission et mais ça interroge quand
même sur notre notre démocratie et sur
notre vie politique parce qu'on est en
train de discuter de qui sera le
candidat idéal pour la droite et le
centre parce que d'origine la représenté
ça pose quand même question alors
qu'est-ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui pour
répondre aux questions est-ce que la
démocratie représentative enfin ça pose
ce type de questions on est pas malade
en France et pourquoi est-ce qu'on se
projette encore vers une figure d'homme
providentielle qu'on cherche absolument
et qu'on trouve pas depuis longtemps
Édouard Philippe va avoir quelques
soucis je crois pour enfin quelques
soucis j'en sais rien en tout cas ils
vont être très nombreux sur son créneau
il y aura Laurent Wauquiez probablement
Gérald Darmanin donc qui ils vont se
disputer pour essayer de passer le
second tour et puis il faut pas oublier
que Marine Le Pen sera là pour prétenter
les sujets liés à l'immigration et au
pouvoir d'achat donc sur une ligne
sociale que vont faire les candidats de
la droite et du centre sur ces questions
là vous n'avez pas répondu à ma question
qu'est-ce qui plaît chez Edouard
Philippe Jean-Luc oui donc même si la
question est inintéressante
je vais essayer d'y répondre non alors
je crois quand on est candidat à
l'élection présidentielle il y a deux
aspects il y a son aspect personnel sur
le fond charisme le rapport la rencontre
d'un homme avec un peuple il y a des
questions politiques sociologiques de
rapport de force
ce qui plaît à certains en tout cas
qu'ils sont pas amoureux de d'Ed
Philippe on peut aussi trouver que c'est
très bien si on est amoureux c'est autre
chose et si on est juste dans la dans
l'analyse dans l'analyse politique face
à Marine Le Pen face à l'extrême droite
la seule alliance qui fonctionne c'est
une de mon point de vue c'est une
alliance qui va du centre gauche à la
droite et de ce point de vue je ne pense
pas qu'il doit Philippe je vais vous
contredire soit sur le même créneau que
vos pieds
c'est justement le problème de vos pieds
c'est qu'il est sûr une tendance plutôt
droite et la droite extrême alors que
Edward Philippe est sur une tendance qui
va de la droite dite républicaine de
gouvernement jusqu'à jusqu'au centre
gauche de mon point de vue la seule oui
bah écoutez une portraits
sur le plan politique quand on regarde
les électeurs et qui disent quand vous
avez 50 à 60% des électeurs de Macron
première version qui dit je pourrais
voter devoir Philippe c'est une partie
du centre gauche ça s'appelle ça
s'appelle ça s'appelle comme ça après ce
qui va l'aider se voir parler les
orientations politiques est-ce que ça
c'est une autre question c'est pour ça
que c'est un équilibre et il sera
condamné donc à faire du en même temps
donc prendre la suite de d'Emmanuel
Macron Christophe vous le situez où
Édouard Philippe alors là je pense aussi
qu'il va essayer
de récupérer l'héritage du macronyme bon
en allant un peu plus à droite Emmanuel
Macron mais pas trop pour les raisons
qui viennent d'être expliquées et que je
partage bon en sachant qu'il y aura un
candidat des républicains vous qui
auquel quelqu'un d'autre mais
probablement vous qui avec des résultats
dont on peut imaginer ce qu'ils seront
mais c'est pas le droit d'aujourd'hui
mais ce qui m'a marqué moi avec Édouard
Philippe c'est qu'au temps on peut
comprendre sa stratégie il est né que au
Havre donc il faut qu'il existe un peu
sur l'espace public et ça a été un peu
le le cas cette semaine mais il commence
quand même à faire des des bourdes j'en
donne une quand même qui est assez
stupéfiante c'est qu'il défend l'idée
d'un concordat avec l'Islam alors là moi
librement tombent parce que de façon
permanente il y a une tension je vous
explique en deux mots de façon
permanente des tensions entre une
religion quelle que soit et les pouvoirs
publics les pouvoirs politiques parce
que c'est la loi de Dieu ou c'est la loi
des hommes bon et ça ça existe depuis
Antigone est-ce qu'il faut respecter ce
que de les dieux disent ou créons
c'est-à-dire le pouvoir politique bon et
ça a toujours existé face à ça il y a
que deux solutions il y en a pas trois
il y en a une qui est la solution
française elle aïcité on sait pas
l'église des états on peut aider un peu
les églises comment restaurant les
églises qui existaient avant 1905 mais
c'est tout le reste il y a une
séparation nette l'autre solution c'est
le Concordat c'est ce qui avait fait
Napoléon pour contrôler une église qui
lui échappait avec les frais les prêtres
réfractaires on a la version française
c'est ce que font les Allemands
aujourd'hui c'est ce que font les pays
arabes musulmans même s'il n'appelle pas
concordat c'est l'idée de contrôler les
églises mais en même temps des soutenir
par exemple quand on est en Allemagne
une partie de ces impôts toute petite
mais va directement aux églises et voilà
et vous mettez moi je suis protestant
moi je suis catholique
en France on est dans le système laïque
et moi je le préfère personnellement bon
mais vous n'allez pas dire qu'il
pourrait pas on peut dire c'est pas mon
cas moi ça me va bon mais on pourrait
penser à un concordat mais c'est un
concordat pour tout le monde sinon c'est
la climatisation des musulmans ou au
contraire une aide imaginez que les
électeurs musulmans puissent payer avec
leurs impôts enfin c'est absurde
stratégie
quand on est en campagne évidemment pour
des risques alors rompre avec Macron
pour Édouard Philippe à un moment à quel
moment non pas avec Macron Macron il est
pardon Emmanuel Macron et de toute façon
il peut pas se représenter donc au
contraire rompre avec Macron ce serait
la pire des choses puisque le potentiel
électoral
le potentiel électoral d'Édouard
Philippe il se trouve sur une partie des
républicains sur une partie
des macronistes et sur une partie je
pense des socialistes qui ne se
reconnaissent pas dans la nups donc il
se serait une erreur magistrale que de
rompre avec Emmanuel Macron
électoral autre question c'est notre
quatrième thème va te trop loin dans nos
déclarations nos analyses sur la police
est-il possible de tout dire de moi
après la mort du jeune Naël le débat sur
la violence policière continue le
réalisateur lajee l'auteur du film à
succès Les Misérables a eu cette sortie
musclée pour le moins cette semaine il
était au Canada pour présenter son
prochain film il a été interrogé sur les
violences policières en France et il dit
la chose suivante la police a le feu
vert pour tuer les noirs et les Arabes
le gouvernement ne donne plus
l'impression d'avoir le contrôle sur les
forces policières on va tout droit vers
une guerre civile azilise c'est choquant
si vous transfiez
choquant on dirait un discours des
Indigènes de la République je trouve ça
dingue et si je me trompe pas il y a
bien le mot exécuté
le mot exact le feu vert pour tuer les
noirs et les arabes on viserait l'État
français viserait des personnes pour
leur couleur de peau ou leur origine
ethnique enfin ça je trouve ça dingue de
dire ça et très très dangereux très très
dangereux pour pour la démocratie
française en fait la réalité et puis
même pour les gens qui sont de d'origine
arabe par exemple qui vivent dans les
banlieues ce qu'ils demandent en fait
c'est plus de sécurité on l'a vu très
récemment avec
les points de deal à Nîmes à Marseille
avec les décès terribles qui a eu
tragique et bien qu'est-ce que demander
à pis 20 en fait les habitants il
demandait davantage de commissariat dans
leur ville donc il y a pas du tout ce
clivage qui existe ça c'est un fantasme
de
certains artistes qui prennent la parole
et simplement je voudrais quand même
ajouter la réalité c'est que les
personnes sur quatre en France victime
de violences volontaires est un policier
ou un gendarme donc en fait la violence
elle s'abat en premier sur les et ça on
en parle pas médiatiquement pendant les
émeutes j'aimerais insister là-dessus il
y a eu 45000 policiers déployés 700
blessés on a retenu et c'est évidemment
tragique mais on a retenu les deux
blessés à Marseille et il faut les
retenir mais pourquoi est-ce qu'on parle
pas des 700 flics qui ont été blessés
je vais vous donner d'autres chiffres le
décompte de nos confrères du média blast
861 décès à la suite d'une intervention
des forces de l'ordre entre 1977 et 2022
parmi ces 861 personnes 86 étaient des
enfants ou adolescents de moins de 18
ans à noter que le nombre de morts liait
à une intervention policière à atteint
un son énorme 2021 52 personnes sont
mortes sur cette seule année 2021 selon
le média basta
je pense que il y a un vrai problème de
doctrine des forces de l'ordre bon
d'abord il y a pas d'outil pour essayer
de limiter le contrôle au faciès qui
évidemment existe sur les noirs et les
Arabes et pas que ça peut être aussi des
indiens ou des asiatiques il y a des
mesures pas évidente par exemple d'avoir
un matricule visible pour qu'on sache
qui a fait quoi de donner un ticket
quand on a eu un contrôle ça veut pas
dire qu'on peut pas être à nouveau
contrôler mais on peut avoir une vague
idée de qui et contrôler et combien de
fois tout ça toujours été refusé et puis
on est le pays d'Europe qui sur les
questions à la fois de maintien de
l'ordre mais aussi de gestion des délits
et le plus mortifère bon prenez un
exemple qui est celui des reflets
d'obtempérer ce qui a tué le jeune Naël
en fin juin de cette année bon en
Allemagne pays plus peuplé donc les
statistiquement il devrait y en avoir
plus et le degré de problème et
d'incivilités sont comparables à la
France un mort en disant nous c'est des
dizaines de morts dans les refuses il y
a un vrai problème et sur le maintien de
l'ordre manifestation dans tout le reste
de l'Europe l'idée c'est la désescalade
on trouve des moyens il y a des piétons
qui sont
les Allemands il y a pas plus de piétons
qui sont fauchés qu'en France par contre
il y a beaucoup plus de morts chez nous
bon et dans les manifestations c'est
c'est un quelque chose d'incroyable tout
le 20e siècle a vu une baisse générale
du degré de violence et début du 20e
siècle c'est l'armée qui tirait sur la
foule à la fin et mai 68 a été un
symbole à cet égard c'est l'idée qu'il
faut tout faire pour qu'il y ait pas de
mort ou de blessés grave depuis la nuit
pour la gestion notamment des
manifestations donc ça c'est faux c'est
totalement
différente
de France un ancien premier film de
France Nicolas Sarkozy je vais vous le
faire écouter il a défendu les forces de
l'ordre par et il dit qu'il n'existe pas
selon lui de violence policière
écoutez-le je vous redonne la parole
on parle à longueur de plateau des
violences policières
qui sont deux mots qui sont parfaitement
incompatibles ça n'existe pas
elle doit être sanctionnée il n'existe
pas de violences policières pour la
bonne et simple raison que la police a
la force de l'ordre de la République
donc parler communément de violences
policières pour la mettre au même niveau
que cette barbarie que l'on voit ça rend
les gens voudrages et ils ont raison
Rosine sur ce point sur l'existence ou
non déjà des violences policières
des propos à mon avis
d'un tel excès que ils sont on ne peut
pas les on ne peut pas les accepter et
en plus il les tient à l'étranger ce qui
est quelque chose il les tient au Canada
et il tient ses propos là en vraiment
d'une violence vis-à-vis de son pays
qui me choque me choque profondément
alors vous avez fait une présentation en
faisant la sommation des choses sur 50
pratiquement 50 ans alors
la somnation de ces de ces morts sur 50
ans c'est quand même une présentation
pardon de vous le dire qui est quand
même largement largement biaisé parce
que alors à ce moment-là on peut on peut
on peut le faire sur bien d'autres
sujets
en tout cas effectivement la police
détient la violence légitime de par ce
que la qualité bah oui c'est parce que
dit Nicolas Sarkozy c'est ce que disent
les textes législatif c'est ce que
disent le pacte social de notre pays
quand la police fait j'allais dire
s'attaque au malfrats c'est pas la lutte
entre deux bandes rivales comme on
essaie de nous faire croire parce que
c'est ça l'histoire qui est en train de
se mener c'est à dire qu'il y a d'un
côté il y aurait une espèce de deux
gants qui s'affronterait non non c'est
la violence qui détient dans la
République la force légitime la violence
légitime alors effectivement il faut
absolument condamner les bavures
policières des propos racistes qui ne
sont pas la majorité des policiers bien
entendu enfin des forces de l'ordre plus
généralement d'ailleurs policiers
gendarmes donc c'est ces propos sont
vraiment
plus que mal à propos ce débat raconte
de nous de notre rapport à la pollution
Luc
ça raconte d'abord que que on peut avoir
une déclaration stupide c'est celle qui
est qui est faite là enfin essayer de se
faire remarquer en disant n'importe quoi
c'est
oui non mais qui dit quoi ou pas c'est
absolument intolérable il n'y a pas de
permis de tuer les Arabes ou les Noirs
dans la police française est absurde
effectivement les violences policières
entre guillemets et le racisme ça dit ça
dit qu'on ne traite pas les questions
qui se posent on a une première question
je vais répéter rapidement et moins bien
ce que Roselyne vient de dire
les rapports de la police avec des
groupes de population c'est pas un
affrontement de gang c'est d'un côté une
force légale et légitime et de l'autre
côté des de la délinquance des formes de
de délinquance il faut le rappeler il
faut le rappeler mais là-dessus par
exemple j'étais frappé que dans toute
cette période il est pas un politique
qui se soit adressé à ses gamins on
s'adresse aux parents on soutient la
police on dit la responsabilité des
parents mais le discours simple qui dit
on meurt pas 16 ans si un flic vous
interpelle arrêtez-vous obtempérer on
est dans un pays droit le flex se
comporte mal avec vous
allez porter plainte contre le flic
allez vous défendre contre le flic le
commissariat ne veut pas la prendre vous
avez la trouille dans le commissariat
vous avez des élus pour faire pour pour
faire ça mais
obtempérer c'est pas une option c'est
obligatoire et ça passe par là avec les
recours première chose deuxièmement on a
un problème non pas de violence
policière des de violence deux policiers
ça ça existe et il faut évidemment les
traiter par la formation par la
répression quand ça se pose même s'il
faut reconnaître qu'ils sont mis à la
durée et la troisième chose que je veux
dire parce que c'est le chose qui me
choque ce sont les choses qui me
choquent le plus c'est est-ce que nous
avons un problème de racisme dans la
police oui oui nous avons un problème de
racisme et je veux dire là-dessus
quelque chose il a 7 que vous avez des
policiers français qui sont sur des
sites ou ils chassent le enfin
écoutez on a des exemples mais alors
vous avez
il y a des policiers français racistes
et l'argument qui me dit c'est seulement
certains et donc c'est comme partout
dans la société que j'entends souvent
est inacceptable parce que un policier
ça ne peut pas ça ne doit pas être dans
un comportement raciste parce que moi si
ma crémière est raciste je change de
crémière je peux changer de crémière si
mon flic est raciste je peux pas changer
de flic il m'interpelle il me met en
garde à vue il m'interroge et ça c'est
inacceptable de considérer qu'après tout
c'est pas si grave que ça il y en a pas
plus d'ailleurs
la réalité
comme comme sacrémière mais simplement
l'État français ne manque pas de les
sanctionner donc ça c'est une réalité et
votre discours rejoint celui de ce de ce
réalisateur parce que vous faites une
sorte de France
de la même manière qu'il dit que qu'il
tue les noirs et les Arabes la même
chose c'est la même chose
j'ai repris par certains politiques la
semaine prochaine une centaine
d'organisation appelle un marché contre
les violences policières et c'est
important le racisme elle dénonce une
politique régressive qui fait le lit de
l'extrême droite et piétine toujours
plus de liberté publique etc etc parmi
les organisations à l'origine de la
marche qui aura lieu le 23 septembre la
France insoumise la CGT ou encore
l'association extinction rébellion
qu'est-ce que ça vous inspire vous
Christophe ce genre de de marche pour
démontrer des violences et le racisme et
je pense que c'est très bien c'est à
dire qu'on avait vu que en 2005 quand il
y avait eu des émeutes et les violences
urbaines tout le monde avait été
paralysé personne n'avait repris ces
questions là là ça n'est pas le cas et
que le monde associatif syndical et
politique se disent il faut pouvoir dire
quelque chose sur ces questions là parce
qu'il y a en effet un racisme qui existe
alors pas chez tous les policiers mais
qui existe et puis il y a un problème de
doctrine de maintien de l'ordre à la
fois sur les affaires délictuelles mais
aussi sur le l'ordre public et ça c'est
décisif ce qui explique pourquoi à la
différence de Mai 68 et grâce à Maurice
Grimaud l'absence de mort depuis les
gilets jaunes on ne compte plus
à Marseille il y a eu deux morts si il y
a deux morts
qui se servent politiquement ce dossier
parce qu'il y a un potentiel électoral
dans ce pays il faut pas les violons
c'est pas mais c'est que dans toute
l'Europe il y a aussi des Black Blocs il
y a aussi des violences il y a aussi des
problèmes
évidemment
sont éborgnés perdre leurs mains sont
laissées entre la vie ou la mort meurent
d'un certain cueille il y a eu deux
morts à Marseille un point une pendant
les gilets jaunes une vieille dame qui a
été tuée par une grande lacrymogène et
un qui vient d'être tué fin juin début
juillet par un ce qu'on appelle un BIM B
en fait une espèce de sac de grenaille
de fer qui en est mort un père de
famille qui passait la par hasard bon
donc il y a des morts
s'il vous plaît on passe à un autre
thème le dernier de cette émission
l'alcool sera-t-il devenu bon pour la
santé on pourrait se demander puisqu'on
a pris pour quoi se mettre que le
gouvernement avait retoqué deux
campagnes de prévention de
sensibilisation Rosine n'est pas du tout
d'accord avec moi elle va nous le dire
pourquoi la Coupe du monde de rugby a
commencé l'une de ces deux campagnes
devaient débuter au même moment et
patatras selon Radio France cette
campagne a été enterrée par le
gouvernement les associations dénoncent
les pressions du lobby du 20 écouté la
réponse du ministre de la Santé
par d'un parent c'est extrêmement
violent mais on a eu et collectivement
le sentiment que dans la période où on
était on avait plutôt intérêt à
recentrer justement l'évoquer sur le
public jeune sur le fait de avoir cette
approche un peu plus par le côté aller
chercher le côté festif plutôt que le
côté culpabilisant c'est est-ce que
c'est un bon choix mauvais choix de
santé publique mais il y a bien une
campagne qui commence le 25 septembre à
renforcer tous les dispositifs de suivi
des conséquences alors madame la
ministre de la Santé expliquez-nous
pourquoi c'est pas une surprise pour
vous que gouvernement que l'exécutif
enterre une telle campagne alors d'abord
il y a pas enterrement d'une campagne
contre l'alcool ou de d'informations sur
l'alcool il y a le remplacement d'une
campagne par une autre moi je suis assez
d'accord avec ce que dit Aurélien
Rousseau c'est très difficile les
campagnes globales de santé publique il
y a d'abord un épuisement très vite des
campagnes il y a le fait de toucher un
public très large fait que finalement
tout le monde s'en tout le monde s'en
moque un peu et avoir des publics
ciblées parce que c'est bien
l'alcoolisme des jeunes qui est une qui
est un vrai problème de santé publique
un problème de sécurité également on l'a
vu encore
on est en train de juger les les gens
qui ont tabassé à mort le chauffeur de
bus le chauffeur de bus à Bayonne là il
y a des conduites en état hyper hyper
alcoolique donc je trouve que les
campagnes ciblées marchent
toujours à
votre direction est-ce qu'il y a des
pressions des lobbies de l'alcool sur le
pouvoir exécutif en général le sucre des
campagnes des lobbies de l'alcool mais
on y résiste
sur la bien sûr on n'est pas
du pays des bisounours je les ai connu
comme ministre de la Santé
je les ai même reçu je leur ai dit merde
c'est clair mais là vous me dites que je
leur ai dit non pardon
vous avez le droit mais la visiblement
on n'a pas sur résister manuel Macron on
a pas su résisté
il y a une campagne qui va être beaucoup
plus mauvaise sur les lobbies de
l'alcool que la campagne généraliste qui
va qui va pas marcher il y a une
tolérance peut-être un peu particulière
pendant le cannabis peut-être plus
simple comme ça le cannabis on a une
politique très répressive et quand c'est
l'alcool on est un petit peu plus cool
Christophe
attendez sur les contrôles routiers par
exemple
sur le cannabis par exemple moi
j'aimerais bien qu'il y ait des
campagnes de prévention aussi utilise
les consommateurs puisque on vise
essentiellement en tout cas dans le
débat publics politiques les dealers
mais il faudrait aussi expliquer que
quand on consomme de la drogue on va
acheter un dealer et ben on participe à
un trafic qui est global donc ça c'est
important de prévenir en fait les
consommateurs de cannabis et de drogues
en général et ça je trouve qu'on ne le
fait pas assez sur l'alcool il faut
différencier deux choses à mon avis le
problème de l'alcoolisme qui est un
véritable fléau et ensuite
la différence qu'il peut y avoir entre
le fait de consommer un verre de vin de
manière festive qui aussi fait partie de
notre art de vivre à la française et je
pense que nos producteurs en tout cas
dans le Bordelais en ce moment
particulièrement ont besoin d'être
soutenu et ça les lobbies font leur
travail qu'on peut déplorer parfois mais
en tout cas c'est ils sont dans leur
rôle Jean-Luc sur cette question je
voyais un petit peu on va pas se
raconter d'histoires
il y a moins de production de de shits
en France que de 20
donc on a des lobbys plus forts sur le
vin ça
je vous demande juste le l'ampleur du
marché français des boissons alcoolisées
c'est 50 milliards d'euros en 2000 2021
700000 emplois c'est beaucoup d'argent
c'est beaucoup d'emplois donc évidemment
que les lobbies existent deuxième
question il faudrait s'interroger sur
l'utilité des campagnes car quand vous
êtes dans une entreprise et que vous
faites de la publicité que vous dépensez
de l'argent vous avez des une analyse de
ce que ça vous a rapporté ou pas là je
suis pas sûr qu'on est cette rigueur là
sur les campagnes de sur les campagnes
sur les campagnes de prévention la
troisième chose mais c'est un clin
d'oeil je suis sûr que c'est Roselyne
Bachelot qui est en cachette à organiser
ça il y a eu une contribution assez
formidable contre la surconsommation
c'est l'incapacité du Stade de France de
fournir suffisamment de bière
aux personnes qui assistaient au match
de rugby au premier match de rugby
contre les All Blacks il y a eu partout
beaucoup des mois le seul problème
Roselyne c'est quand même temps il y
avait pas assez d'eau
et donc voyez de temps en temps la
prohibition a des effets pervers comme
Emmanuel Macron boit cuit sec un verre
comme ça au mois de juin un verre de
bière il est dans son rôle c'est-à-dire
il est dans une chose festive on devient
une société absolument mais
incroyablement comme on dit oui c'est
vraiment ce sujet
c'est pas si dangereux que ça de boire
de vous savez j'ai été au moment du vote
de la loi Eva j'étais dans l'opposition
j'ai voté la loi tabac alcool contre mon
groupe on m'a même retiré j'étais le peu
la porte-parole j'étais l'orateur du
groupe on m'a retiré 3h avant de monter
à la tribune mon rôle d'orateur du
groupe pour le donner
Charente de la région de Cognac donc je
sais je sais avoir dans ce domaine du du
courage du courage politique et les les
gens les lobbies m'expliquaient à
l'époque que on allait ruiner le sport
parce que le sport marchait avec les
buvettes etc on m'a raconté mais des
calandredennes pas croyable évidemment
rien de tout ça ne s'est passé
heureusement des structures enfin des
choses ont été mises en dérivation pour
soutenir le sport sans que ça passe par
les buvettes et je dois dire que ça
continue les tireuse à bière etc bon
j'ai refusé au moment de la de la d'un
certain nombre de manifestations
sportives qu'elles soient financées par
des grands fabricants de Bierges je ne
le regrette pas mais là en l'occurrence
c'est un très mauvais procès et c'est
quelqu'un qui a pris suffisamment de
risque dans sa vie politique pour vous
le dire pour ne pas être accusé de
faiblesse Christophe le mot de la fin
sur ce point je vais être rapide je
pense que la loi est vin est un bon
exemple parce que 92 absolument parce
qu'elle était difficile à faire passer
et heureuse une rappelle ici parce qu'il
y avait des oppositions très très fortes
à droite et pas qu'à droite mais surtout
à droite et c'est très bien qu'elle soit
passée et elle a été efficace parce que
c'est l'idée d'interdire la publicité
surtout ces produits là et ça c'est
positif bon donc il faut aller dans ce
sens là je préfère ça la prohibition si
on prend l'exemple du cannabis là aussi
l'art à la française on est les premiers
fumeurs d'Europe et de loin par les plus
répressif et les plus répressifs aussi
donc la répression ne sert à rien si ce
n'est à remplir des prisons et à créer
des points de deal qui permet au
business et aux raquettes de pouvoir
s'implanter dans les quartiers donc
serait mieux le légalisé par contre le
contrôler ne pas faire de publicité
faire exactement ce que la loi Eva a
prévu et je pense que tout le monde
s'emporterait mieux bon comme chaque
semaine on va terminer cette émission
par un top flop je vous pose à chacun
une question très simple qui a marqué
l'actualité la semaine en bien ou en mal
cher Rosine vous commencez par un flop
alors top par un top les extraordinaires
découvertes des industries de santé le
vaccin contre le cancer du poumon le B
Fortus contre la bronchiolite en
traitement préventif et ce qui est assez
extraordinaire c'est qu'en réfléchissant
ça ça ouvre tous les dossiers qu'on a
ouvert entre nous c'est à dire l'impact
sur l'espérance de vie le problème des
retraites les l'augmentation
considérable des dépenses de santé donc
désespoir formidables qui changent
complètement le mode de fonctionnement
de la société mon flop c'est la montée
d'un rêve cauchemardesque d'une société
sans enfant la corendone Airlines ce qui
a des zones sans enfant les
restaurateurs les hôteliers le livre
d'Hélène gâteau pourquoi j'ai choisi
d'avoir un chien et pas d'enfant et bien
là aussi c'est la même problématique la
chute de la natalité pas d'enfants des
mouvements écologistes qui disent
d'avoir des enfants c'est contraire à
l'environnement bon on a un monde sans
enfants
qui ira à la messe célébrée par le pape
François à Marseille je trouve que c'est
un geste politique fort qui rappelle et
d'ailleurs qui ne se pose pas la laïcité
puisque la loi de 1905 n'empêche pas les
présidents d'assister occulte et
j'aimerais qu'on revienne simplement sur
l'exemple générale de Gaulle qui le
faisait et qui ne communique pas bien
qu'il soit un fervent catholique il est
séparé les deux fonctions je trouve que
c'est un beau geste et mon flop c'est
cette campagne publicitaire de Sephora
avec les hits jabuses le sport devrait
être un mouvement d'émancipation pour
les femmes elle envoie qu'elle promet
une forme d'idéologie qui vise à couvrir
la femme et et c'est l'alliance
finalement de cette idéologie islamiste
avec le capitalisme qui cherche
simplement un nouveau marché et je
trouve ça déplore Christophe votre top
mon top c'est la décision qui a été
annoncée par le ministre Beaune des
transports des trains à 49 € par mois
pour l'ensemble des terres et les
Intercités mais un top qui demande quand
même à être confirmé parce que c'est un
modèle qui a été expérimenté en
Allemagne qui a très bien marché trop
d'une certaine façon puisque les trains
étaient totalement bondés mais c'est ça
dont on a besoin si on veut lutter
contre le réchauffement climatique c'est
absolument clé et on sait qu'en
Allemagne c'est les régions qui payent
et en France comme vous le savez le TER
c'est aussi des régions donc est-ce que
les régions vont accepter il y a un
petit doute sur ça mais disons que c'est
vraiment un dossier brûlant et je pense
que c'est très positif s'il est
implémenté et mon flop c'est la décision
que j'ai appris tout à l'heure enfin
hier soir exactement c'est
l'interdiction des visas pour les
Maliens nigériens et autres burkinabè
artiste on parle bien de cela bon qu'on
sanctionne les dirigeants des jeunes
militaires qui ont pris le pouvoir j'ai
absolument aucun a pas de problème il
s'agit évidemment de défendre toutes les
institutions démocratiques mais les
artistes ont toutes les opinions
politiques du monde il y en a qui sont
pour d'autres comptes et on a tout
intérêt à garder des liens avec la
société de ces pays-là et des artistes
en sont parmi les meilleurs
représentants et c'est totalement
absurde et dramatiques pour eux de
pouvoir les interdire
d'être d'être honnête mais c'est pas
bien mais pour moi l'événement le plus
important c'est la victoire du 15 de
France passe au All Blacks et donc je me
suis dit je vais faire un top bon
évidemment j'étais un peu refroidie hier
le match de l'équipe réserve mais je me
suis dit avec constance il faut les
soutenir c'est un sport formidable ça
crée ils ont gagné ça crée une ambiance
extraordinaire et le pays a bien besoin
de victoire pour lui remonter le moral
le flop c'est vous savez vous partez un
peu en vacances vous revenez et vous y
croyez pas j'entends Jean-Luc Mélenchon
qui fait des déclarations
jadis sur le l'interdiction voile la
laïcité intégrale nous expliquer que la
bagasse c'est une question de mode et
qu'il est formidable d'inviter un
rappeur antisémite et homophobe dans le
dans leur fait et je me suis dit à ce
moment-là Jaurès Mitterrand revenait ils
sont devenus fous merci à tous les
quatre c'est la fin de cette émission
merci d'avoir participé un énorme salut
à vous derrière votre écran c'était la
première de la saison on était ravi de
vous retrouver je vous rappelle que vous
pouvez revoir cette émission en replay
sur notre plateforme public sénat.fr et
nous comme d'habitude on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine même jour même heure
et même endroit bye bye
[Musique]